you know my guest as the angry video
game nerd he reviews and plays games and
reviews movies on his site cinemassacre
calm looks over cult movies and shows
especially during october with monster
madness kick started his own motion
picture named after his most famous
character and was nice enough to kick
the crap out of me in many of his videos
and I am still suffering from many of
those bruises
please welcome james rolfe how are you
sir pretty good not bad yeah bad um I'm
gonna start with the number one question
that I get all the time about you do we
really hate each other do we really hate
each other that's like the number one
question I always get even though I
thought we made it pretty clear you know
I mean I really still like yeah do you
hate each other starring each other's we
loathe each other I thought it was
pretty obvious that you know I can't
stand you right down to we're wearing
opposite colors and everything oh yeah
you got me in lumberjack outfit here uh
so do people really ask that if they do
that there's a video where you literally
say it's a joke and even to this day I
get people still asking so do you really
hate James royalty really hate video
game nerd well at the Emmy well that's
hard to believe but anyone would still
think that but actually it's kind of a
compliment in a way that you know we're
actors you know so it's like we if we
made it we did a good job if people see
it as like you know it was it was real I
still found out pretty hard to believe
that it's I've had cuz at times I think
like oh they're just sort of you know if
it's an email it's like oh they're just
being a jerk or something like that but
like I've had people conventions like
really ask me honestly I like no no it's
it's that we star on each other's videos
do you think we just go to separate
trailers or no word but I'm with you ago
when this feud started and we we didn't
announce that it was fake uh like they
were getting so angry - how dare you say
these words about james rolfe in the
nerd and to me that was just great
that's the greatest thing in the world
when people like you said just gets so
invested I could see it before when we
were separate or both and you did a
video and then I would do a video when
we're both in the same room like doing
obvious choreography it's like okay
somebody has to put together this was
point
Oh like the gag is up now you get it
right but apparently not
um you start the angry video game nerd
as kind of a V log about in Jekyll and
hi there were no game clips nothing like
they it was just a short video talking
about
painted it it was episode 2 which is the
first time I appeared on screen in
character and that one had very little
of the game it was mostly a character
study sort of after you did that what
made you want to do more of that what
made you say hey there's like
possibilities with this I didn't think
there were any at that time I thought I
thought it was what it was I thought
that was kind of the culmination the
character right there it's his most
hated game and that's it's sort of just
a guy coming to terms with his childhood
and in this game that he played while
he's a kid very much like myself it was
kind of it kind of really was sort of um
based on reality but just taken to a
whole other level just exaggerated we
make it into a character and make it
funny but it was just something that sat
in my closet on VHS tapes it was kind of
traded around with friends you know I
make some copies hand them out and
people always come up to me but I saw
that video you did that was really funny
and it was just one in a million it was
just with tons and tons of videos I
would do because I'd grow up making
movies and that was just one other thing
and it could have been anything
that caught on but that's what it was
and it wasn't what I expected but video
games are so popular and I
underestimated how popular they really
are because I don't think anybody else
would remember those same games but then
when we started putting the videos on
YouTube then it became you know had such
a big responsibly to it became bigger
and bigger and bigger and then it was
like okay well this could keep going
there's plenty of NES games out there so
blending of bad ones definitely oh yeah
well when I first saw your videos of the
nerd doing the old Nintendo games I
remember because I was toying around the
idea that nostalgia critic because I I
love nostalgia was going through the
same phase that you and most of America
was I guess at that time at least people
our age and when I saw you doing it and
that people really responding well to
and I said okay so this can be a thing
you can talk about things that most
people would say are childish or from
the pass or they're not worth talking
about and you can actually make like a
big deal oven you can make entertaining
it there's an audience what did you
think when you saw people actually
getting into stuff that many worse
was just childish and not important at
the time I was so surprised because it
was just gaming was just a hobby like if
anything I thought I wasted a lot of
time as a youth but really it was just
homework for the future so when I was
supposed to be doing my real homework
I'm playing video games after you listen
for the kids right now yeah the school
erotic video games that's where you live
well I think things are a lot different
now but uh Nick is now there's so much
out there but uh at that time it was
research for the future but uh you know
back then there was no internet there
was no way to learn about other games
other than just by playing them but now
we're sort of educating people and like
this is this is our history we're
preserving history really in a way
because people are interested in the
past and that's what I underestimated I
thought you know like you said I thought
that people would only be interested in
whatever's new whatever's current but no
really we're all interested in the past
we like to go back and catch up with
music games movies whatever that came
out before we were alive so um and it's
nice you know they might have like you
know a big big brother sister who has a
Nintendo and they might go back and play
a lot of the games and it's not like
they sell them anymore they they they
that they're everything is downloadable
now but they do but you can't actually
just buy a Nintendo console in the
stores now so it's kind of like we do
own a piece of history if you still have
that stuff from when you're a kid so
then it's kind of like I like why not
point a camera at it and talk about it
and show it in a video it's like
show-and-tell and you're giving a
history lesson yeah I think it's
important to preserve pop culture
history and I had no idea people would
be so interested in it but they are the
character the nerd is very different
from you he swears a lot he's angry and
he screams and stuff where you're a very
nice person uh what were the
inspirations for that character were
made you who are you trying to channel
in order to get that five
I don't know I'm glad I'm a nice person
no actually I'm acting right now I'm
really an ask everybody yeah yeah so go
in the videos yeah no but no no I hear
that all the time everybody always says
well you're nothing like the character
which is true I'm glad I'm nothing like
the character but uh I mean I've had
angry bosses before and stuff so it's
like I kind of just like take it from
things I know or things I've experienced
the whole getup is kind of like the 80s
nerd like the stereotypical nerd from
Revenge of the Nerds and all those type
of movies a lot of just a combination it
just real-life things I guess just kind
of throw them all together
if any Pitino bosses you and want to
name or anything like that correct
like actual name get their names so we
can go we can say thank you for being
the big as a whole we've ever seen
because that gave her to you know our
favorite a Oh ha ha
yeah like someone's like the actual like
things that you know say like I had
bosses scream and curse and everything
and like I'd be like ok and then I
thought that's kind of like where some
of the you know like yeah where the
mannerisms come from so you did an
IndieGoGo for a movie based on the Angry
Video Game Nerd it took several years
out of your life and had big effect many
of the practical effects and giant
monsters and all sorts of craziness uh
that must have had a big toll on your
life I think most people could see that
it has uh would you do it again if you
had the opportunity no not like that
well that was that was an IndieGoGo
campaign so like I had to finish it I
had no choice then so and so I finished
it you know took took years but had to
get it right you know I couldn't just
release it without it being finished
obviously but no I would I would never
do one like that again because it's like
that was just suicide it was like let's
have a plane let's have a tank let's
have robots and subs ahhmm be let's have
giant monster destroying buildings
let's have flying saucers and let's have
you know this and that every scene is in
a different location
and you have to get all these locations
and all these people and everything and
just every shot you know watch the movie
every time you see a new shot it's a new
setup new place new time new everything
this next movie you have to be a little
more like like simple like maximum have
to be two people in a room talking you
know that's that would be like star
something like focusing on two guys like
trying to get alpha rumors yeah yeah but
no not really just I just don't think
it's going to be as epic on that kind of
scale because that kind of thing just
takes so long to make and the thing is
like I don't like the restrict
imagination I just wanted to prove that
it could be done that you could be you
could be that far out there you could be
that wild with your imagination then
just go out and do it it just you know
it's a lot harder than it would be if
you did something more low-key so you
got to pick your battle but but I hope
it encourages people to you know not
have to limit their imagination because
it's easy to get discouraged and think
like oh well that's impossible and I'll
never be able to do that because um the
thing that the common thing with
independent films is that you want to
make something that's like a drama or
something something without special
effects or anything like that because
you you leave that to the big huge the
Avengers type budgets you know with it
with like two hundred million dollars
and stuff like that like imagination and
special effects that's all for the
big-budget people leave it to them you
know you low-budget indie films now you
don't do special effects we said fuck
that we're doing special effects and
we're because I don't think imagination
should be measured by a dollar symbol I
think even if you have ten bucks go out
and make a movie do whatever it is it
might have to be just a flip book at
that point or whatever but you know
animate it with stick figures but
whatever you have available at your
resources you should be able just use it
and just use it creatively and to just
max out what you can do with that and
not limit your imagination and also I
think it's funny when you see something
and it's like on a string or you know
things that are like made of plastic to
me that's more tangible it's more
interesting than you know these like
really detailed CG
animations everything so I like to see
things that are real it was so weird I
never realized how desensitized I kind
of got how my CG there is I don't really
have too much against CG I think it's
overused but uh you know it's a fine
tool but there was something so strange
when I see a giant monster like at
Excalibur uh and I know it's it's
obviously a guy in a suit it's obviously
a model but when he hits it it's like I
know that the physical hit I'm actually
gonna feel that when it impacts because
it's really there yeah where I can see
like a CG Godzilla hitting a movie it
won't have I won't have this be a
connection because I know it's it's CG
I'm just so used to seeing that uh so
was very interesting to see like actual
physical destruction again yeah that it
that isn't it's somehow it actually
feels more real even though it looks
more fake yeah that's very very
stressful because then a lot of things
we you know put a guy in this elaborate
costume that that's that takes like an
hour to put on and he's got these
tentacles that come out and these wings
and there's people operating the wings
with the strings and people are have
poles on the tentacles we have to remove
the poles later and post but then you'd
have this building that's the size of
him and he's going to smash it and
you're going to get one take sometimes
out and if it goes wrong if it doesn't
break the way it's supposed to break or
something happens then it's like it's
over and you're done so we're just so
stressed out you know but then once it
happened it was awesome it was like oh
my god we did that but yeah on the
blu-ray it goes into more detail about
how we did all that stuff and really
candid it just shows like raw footage
from like the behind the scenes stuff of
us putting that all together yeah it was
crazy but I was I was like kicking
myself up until the day when we were
trying to shoot all that really
elaborate stuff because it got to the
point where I was like this is
impossible and nobody does like physical
effects like this everything's in
computer now so it's hard to even find
people to build that stuff for you and
my kid was about to be born at this time
so we this is this was weeks before the
birth so it was like but one of my
builders called it he called it a brick
wall deadline it's when you have no
choice but this is it
if you don't get it now you're not going
to get it so it was just up until that
point I'm thinking why the hell did I do
this this is so complicated and this is
so hard to do and I'm just going to
completely fail but then it all happened
that it all came together at the last
minutes like yes we did it and then I
remember then I was like now I remember
why I did it in the first place because
it was so much fun it was so awesome
when he actually did it and pulled it
off but everything leading up to that
was like like oh fuck how is this gonna
work you know
speaking of your kid how his fatherhood
oh it's awesome my kid is amazing I have
a daughter she's almost 2 now and she's
really funny she's uh I mean what can
you say she's amazing
and she started she's starting to talk
actually pick it up a the nerd isms like
saying fucking shit or anything like no
I'm trying to keep her far from that
it's difficult I have to schedule
filming videos around her her naps and
everything and it's so complicated
having a kid in the house and trying to
work in the house and then you know I'd
go I go into the next room to grab
something I got to go grab a battery or
a wire or something and I go over there
and then also daddy and she runs in like
a clings to my leg and like oh I'm so
sorry I gotta go I'll see you later I
need to I need to go in the other room
and curse and throw things do adult
things what I'm saying I got I got AG
like video games I gotta go to work I
gotta go um scream shitload of fuck and
stuff that's what I do so yeah it's it's
really really difficult with the kid in
the house but but she's awesome she's uh
um once again yeah what can you say
she's amazing I gotta ask
where's game you ever played well dr.
Jamison yeah yeah I know
that's the worst game that you can play
actually there's there's there's games
that you can't play like plumbers don't
wear ties is almost there it's like like
that's hardly a game you know you have a
little bit where you choose what happens
next but it's mostly you're just
passively watching it but then there's
games like like big rigs is a game where
okay it kind of plays like a game
but you can't you can't lose in it and
it's a I took all glitch and then Desert
Bus where you just drive for eight hours
and then crazy bus there's games like
that that just don't qualify as game so
I think you care is a level below dr.
Jekyll mr. Hyde where but you don't even
think they are game yeah point like
there's just nothing to do with them
yeah and in dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde like it
comes down to a personal thing a lot
it's kind of just like you know what was
the game that really pissed you off as a
kid and then then you see sort of
celebrate it afterwards in retrospect
that this is this game that you remember
pissing you off and now it's kind of
like you know it's nostalgia for bad
memories but it's like a positive kind
of a you know but let each everybody
says et worst game of all time it's not
you know it's it's disappointingly not
I'd have to say but at the same time
it's great to have that that moniker you
want to have something a point to say
this is the worst game of all time and
with such a great story which which
obviously had to be a movie like there's
no way that would have sucked it's just
an episode like I'm going to review ET
like there isn't that much to complain
about with it I mean it's bad but it's
not that bad
but the story behind it like the whole
you know like those kind yeah and of
course we invented our own fictional
like twist to that whole thing so
anybody seen the movie knows our whole
twist to that the character needs to
have a kryptonite and that's what it was
eta is the kryptonite to the nerd and he
has to face his phobias and then when
you can add a whole bunch of fictional
conspiracy stuff to it that's always fun
like like the Mario 3 thing I did where
the game is possessed by the devil you
know I love that kind of stuff coming up
with alternate realities to things yeah
like you thought it was just a game but
really it was the destruction of the
universe that was about to happen it's
like really just in Mario Bros 3 you
knew yeah it just happens to be that
ones they're not not to not not one it's
just three for some reason um what is x4
cinemassacre calm mourner videos
obviously and more more James I hear ya
right now a lot of recovering actually a
lot of recovering a lot of maintenance
but most of the same really most of uh
there'll be some more nerds only when
there's a good idea though I can't that
they're gonna the videos would suck if I
just kept cranking them out as fast but
what's really fresh and what's really my
focus this year's bored James actually
because uh bored James has been absent
for two years now and I know we ended it
on this epic dream phone video and I
don't think I'm ever going to top the
dream phone episode but there is a
continuation after that and and I've
been trying to do it I was trying to
bring bored James back last year and I
had a whole story arc planned and I was
going to just try to just get one out a
month and then finishing the movie just
had to take priority it was like okay
this isn't happening this year I was
trying to squeeze it in but you know I
was killing myself so bored James was
delayed till this year but now I
actually I'm starting on it I am working
on new episodes and uh I'm really
excited for bored James this year so
that's going to be my most priority and
and then of course monster badness you
know that that usually starts about now
because it takes almost the year because
you got to watch all the movies first
some of them you can remember but like
ones that you might need to see again to
refresh your memory or ones you haven't
seen at all it's that's 31 movies so you
got to watch them all then you got to
write them you got to write the the
reviews and then you know so usually we
start about now but I had to do that
whole Friday the 13th marathon so doing
that pretty much set back the start for
monster madness so because it was on
Friday the 32 do it because it's Friday
the 13th we had to Friday 13th this year
so far there's yet another um but I'm
done with those videos I didn't want to
do that for monster madness because I
felt like doing a third of monster
madness just a Friday 30th yeah we gonna
hold yeah so low chasin down yeah I was
just too much with too many of those
movies for that so yeah so mostly web
videos but eventually once I once I'm
caught up again then I'll stay
on another movie but uh which I've
narrowed down like six different feature
film ideas we'll see what Aaron down yes
yes I narrow down to six we'll see which
one takes the lead I was actually
writing well uh one this past winter and
as I was pretty much right after the new
year and like January into February I
was like writing this one then after I
wrote down like most of like the whole
synopsis to it I was like okay this is
insane
this is this this is too complicated so
alright I'm gonna hold that one off for
now
and then I'm going to try to come up
with something that's a little more
feasible and quicker it's hard with the
internet because everything's a quick
fix everything's like constant output
and you know movies aren't like that
movies take years so it's gotta be the
right you know one you're like this is
the one dedicate all that time to you
know you're gonna want to fit it yeah
you got to love it you got to really
love like which one is it that you love
the most
so yeah do you have anything planned
like that like that you've been tossing
around your head I have I'm sure you
identify with this like there's actually
about that same amount like maybe six
ideas it's like I want these out before
I die
that's just finding the time yeah
because but it's kind of a fair trade
because I love this job and I love doing
the nostalgia critic I love them in a
job where you can pretty much do
whatever you want you're allowed to do
whatever you want it's amazing but yeah
that's applied to man like you said I
mean it's like it it does take up time
and if you you can do a quick you can
rush it out I'm sure people watch it but
if you want to get better and you want
to sing really you need the time
dedicate it to it yeah so it's it's
tough it's definitely tough but at the
same time you're still a loud majority
of your time to do what you love so it's
right yeah I guess you have fun the most
efficient ways to make it like good for
yourself because like the nerd movie was
just a checklist of things I wanted to
do like okay let's say this is the only
movie I ever get a chance to make let's
say I never get a second chance to ever
make another movie then like okay well
then I'm going to put everything into
this movie that I've ever wanted to do
so I want to throw a dummy off
the top of Vasquez rocks all right we
check that off we check we checked
almost everything off they wanted to do
a cinematic bucket list is what it
sounds it is it's a total cinematic
bucket list the only thing that I that I
regret that I did not get in the movie
that um that you know you can't get
everything but I wanted to get um a
window jump I want to jump through a
window in slow motion you've done boxes
you don't buy kinda very you're asking
um our prop guy guy built sets Jim J
rise you're asking like ever done like
anything with breaking a window or glass
yeah no not yet you're just like I
really want to do that someday yeah I
always made so bad man can always break
through those windows like they're just
nothing I was like that really his
shoulders ever break when he has to go
through their head or whatever um I like
to add every interview with two polar
opposite questions uh the first one
being whether personally or
professionally what is the toughest
thing you've ever had to go through and
how to get through it
oh I've been through a lot really I mean
nothing more than an ordinary human
being I don't think like you know
probably uh you know like like I don't
think I have any like I don't think I'd
have like a like that awesome of an
autobiography compared to like rock
stars and you know big big-time
celebrities but for just an average
person I mean I've been through some
interesting stuff I think making the
movie was the most was the craziest
thing I've ever done and I guess if
movies weren't that crazy to make then
everybody would do them and sometimes it
seems like everybody is because there's
so many there's so many movies out there
that exist that it's that really a
miracle if you think about it but yeah I
would say that was the hardest because
it was just like without without like
going into like a whole like story I
like it like it's like I wrote about
everything down as a making-of like I'm
going to do this whole making of
documentary tell everything with the
movie from start to finish and then it
turned out just with that script was
like three and a half hours that's only
me it's not even counting the other
interviews that we were going to
cut in there so we ended up on the
blu-ray it was actually kind of like
little segments of like let's get all
the main stuff like here's the cast
here's the special effects but if I had
to like tell the whole thing I got like
I just couldn't fit it in it's too long
of an answer to elaborate why but it was
a it was extremely stressful like I
couldn't even and then you know having a
kid was stressful but that's pretty
average like lots of people go through
that but yeah those are the hard things
I can think of that are the easiest to
say without a long long answer I guess
and finally what is the proudest thing
whether personal or professional that
you've ever done but I think that
processing those mom was my kid because
really after that then you don't think
about it at first but then later you're
like oh my god I created a human being
and now it talks to me very cool this
has been shut up and talk with james
rolfe and we will see you next time
yeah stuff like this it doesn't really
matter what would you say like let out
just a big laugh just big one right now
no bigger than my ha ha ha jerk oh how
easy how cheesy yeah that's really good
I really do